I'm going to make statements and we
're going to make very
detailed statements but there won't be any
response at the end of the press conference
we're going to start
so we're going to have a
press conference in two voices so I'm going to
start then  then I will leave the
house of life
so on June 8, 2023 around 9:30 a.m. the
police services
were called in for an attack in progress
on the package which is a large
public garden located in downtown Annecy
l  he investigation made it possible to establish the
following chronology of the facts a
first sequence on a playground
and in the immediate vicinity during
which 5 victims will be injured
four children and an adult all injured
by stabbing
cause thanks
to the intervention of several third parties in the
immediate vicinity of the playground
followed by a final sequence with an
arrest of the respondent 300
meters from the playing area by 5 backstage areas
the arrest occurs when
in question came from quite a few
stab wounds to a man who is therefore
the sixth victim it was a shot
fired by a police officer present which made it
possible to stop the action of the
respondent and allowed his arrest on the
sixth  victim who had therefore been
injured beforehand by white army
was hit by a shot from the police officer the
defendant strongly resisted his
arrest there is therefore at this stage
a single scene with a single perpetrator and
a single weapon
in the procedural framework  therefore, as soon as
the commission of the facts was informed,
the Annecy public prosecutor's office opened a
flagrant investigation of the counts of attempted
assassination which is a crime punishable by
life imprisonment and the
central management of the
judicial police was seized  of the investigation the
Annecy public prosecutor's office immediately
overran the scene the suspects
were placed in police custody at 9:45 a.m. his police
custody was extended
for 24 hours which ended
took place yesterday the public prosecutor's office of Annecy
today opened a judicial investigation
of the heads of attempted assassination and
rebellion with weapons two
investigating judges of the judicial court
of Annecy were co-seized the public prosecutor's office
requested its placement of the
provisional tensions  he was presented this morning to
two investigating judges who indicted him
on these heads of incubation and
he did not wish to speak before
his magistrates
following his indictment he was
presented to the judge of the freedoms of
detention whom he placed in
pre-trial detention
on the situation of the victims for
ease of understanding I will
use the term victim only
for the physically injured people
even if obviously we consider and
as victim all the direct witnesses
of the  facts I am thinking in particular of the parents
of young injured children who are
extremely shocked today so you
are so physically injured victims have
been medically taken care of so we have
four children and two adults to
date no longer have their vital prognosis
involved  all the victims were able to be
examined by the forensic department
on the children the four children are
still hospitalized to this day out
of the four children we have two
children of French nationality who
were at the park with their grandmother they
are from Haute-Savoie these
two children
one is a young boy born in February
2021 who initially had a
vital prognosis who was the victim of two
stab wounds with wounds
in particular abdominal thoracic he had to
undergo emergency surgery
the second child is a small  girl
born in August 2020 who also had a
vital prognosis initially with
three Racing grids in particular she
also underwent
emergency surgery the third
victim is a little girl of
British nationality who was born in
March 2020 who was on vacation in Annecy
with her parents she was in
absolute emergency at the time of the intervention of the
emergency services and her vital prognosis was
not engaged she was the victim of a
stab wound and she should be able to
leave the hospital in the next few
days  still has a little girl who
the fourth minor victim who is a
little girl of Dutch nationality
born in August 2021 who was transferred to
the University Hospital of Geneva by
the emergency services the parents who are
present with their child in the hospital
do not  have not yet been able to be heard by the
investigators
this little girl was in
absolute emergency but her vital prognosis was
never engaged because of the care
immediately provided on the spot a
request for international criminal imprint
was sent to the Swiss authorities who
mandated our  asks a
forensic doctor to examine this child this
child this forensic doctor told us
so Swiss forensic doctor that this
little girl suffered three
wounds but none in the vital area so
that's for the four children there is
still only  then two adults who
were injured by stabbing an adult
who is a man of
French nationality born in 1947 who was
slightly injured with a wound in the
elbow and who was already able to return to his
home and then we have the
sixth victim of this  is a victim who
suffered several wounds there are stab wounds
and a gunshot wound
the vital prognosis of
this victim was committed and
required
emergency surgery to date his vital prognosis
n  he is no longer involved and he was able to be
heard by the investigators that is about
the situation of the victims on the
course of the police custody he
was examined twice
parameters which declared his state of
health compatible with  his police custody the
blood tests for narcotics and
alcohol were carried out they
turned out to be negative
he was the subject during his police
custody of a simple parameter examination
psychiatrist who considered that his state
of health  was compatible with a
hearing in police custody the
psychiatrist noted the absence of
frank delusional elements, however premature to
assess the
possible absence or presence of
psychiatric pathologies at this stage the
police officer refused to comment
throughout his police custody during his
arrest he therefore carried
a folding knife type weapon which
was the weapon used in the attack
he had on him two Christian images
a cross around his neck
480  euros in cash and a Swedish driving license
on the personality elements
we have to date the
indictment of Syrian nationality born in
1991 he declared to the
administrative department that he entered France on
October 26, 2022 he filed an application
for  asylum on October 27, 2022 at the
Isère prefecture this application
sent to OFPRA on November 22, 2022
was rejected on the grounds that he
already benefited from protection in Sweden this
rejection decision was notified to him
electronically on  June 4, 2023 he
benefits on the day of the attack from a
right of residence in France
from the first elements collected on his
journey he would have arrived in Sweden in
2013 from Turkey he would have
left this country in May 2022 to
join Italy  and Switzerland before
arriving in France he would be married father
of a child born in April 2020 informs me
international judicial cooperation
will confirm these elements
the organization the register was seized by
the park edencies elsewhere at this  effect
on his situation in France in Annecy he
would be homeless therefore without a fixed address
Annecy the first testimonies
collected they therefore lived in the
common areas of a building in the center
of Annecy he is unknown to the
police and justice services in
France on  his motivation
as it stands, it is premature to
assess the motivations for this
act, in particular with regard to the absence of a
statement by the defendant both
during his custody and before the
investigating judges and before the  judge
of freedoms of detention witnesses
heard by the investigators indicated
having heard him mention his wife his daughter
and pronounce the name Jesus Christ the
investigations to come under the authority
of the two investigating judges causes
will relate in particular to his
environment  his career and his loss of
sound given, as indicated during
my previous press briefing, no
terrorist motivation appears at this
stage but the Annecy prosecutor's office, as
is customary, remains in contact with the
national anti-terrorist prosecutor's office
before giving the floor to  Mr.
Life, in particular on the means deployed
in the context of this investigation, I wanted to
end this point for with a point on
the care of victims and
witnesses of the attack, in particular to indicate
the association for the assistance of
local victims of life.  I know
was mobilized by the Annecy prosecutor's office
so from the first minutes following
the attack the trained staff was
able to get in touch with the victims
and guide them the victims left and
their families will all benefit
from individual support  by
the victims' aid association
all the victims hospitalized in
France were examined by
forensic doctors within the
judicial medical units of Grenoble and
Annecy and they were all able to
benefit from
multidisciplinary care in  In this context,
all of the direct witnesses, I am thinking
in particular of the high school student who was present a
few meters from the crime scene, were
able to hear the investigators in a single place, therefore within the
departmental council in the premises
that were made available to us.
and benefit following
this hearing from a full
psychological support this care
continues and will continue the prefect of
Isère has also mobilized
the association for the assistance of victims of his
department to take care of the
families  children hospitalized in
Grenoble la viche des savoirs invites
so it is the
local victims' aid association invites witnesses who
were close to the event to
contact them I will give you the
telephone number for
legal support and  psychological so the
number to use I will put it back is
04 50 52 90 75
the Annecy prosecutor's office has been in contact with
the consular authorities for
foreign victims and the
Annecy bar is going to set up a
specific permanence for
the  accompaniment of the victims in connection
with the associations of assistance to the
victims Mr Dany the word
no we said hello thank you
Madam the public prosecutor
I can indeed say
a few words on the mobilization of the
investigators of the judicial police therefore
the parquet floor immediately  seized the
central direction of the
judicial police following the Commission
of the aggression and the investigators of
our judicial police department
of Annecy were therefore able to arrive
immediately on the spot in any case in
a time very close to the action for
start the investigations in view of
the scale of the crime scene the number
of victims and the sensitivity of the
case the decision was taken at the
regional level to dispatch reinforcements
to support our local colleagues
in Annecy thus arrived on site
very  quickly the investigators from
Chambéry then from Lyon we can
say that approximately 1h30 after the effect we
were about fifty investigators from
the south-east judicial police on site
to develop the investigations
both on the crime scene at the level of
the playground and on the route of
the aggressor to his place
of arrest but investigations
also developed around the
questioning by decision of the central director
of the judicial police at midday
national reinforcements were  mobilized
from Nanterre and Levallois reinforcements
arrived judicial police officers
but also
investigators specializing in certain
specific topics, so in the
middle of the day the day before yesterday about a
hundred investigators from the
judicial police were dedicated to this
investigation
beyond the  mobilization in
numbers, we have also deployed
specialized investigators to
carry out investigations over the
time of the flagrante delicto and to maintain
complete on the crime scene first
the scientific police officers of Annecy de
Lyon but also of the national
police service  scientific décully
were dispatched to deal with the area where the
assaults took place and to recover with the
necessary rigor the elements and traces and clues necessary to
develop the judicial investigation
concerning the collection of testimonies
the Pharos platform,
which is  generally made up of about
ten investigators intended to
collect all the testimonies and
information that can and make it possible
to usefully guide the investigation so in
less than 48 hours it is more than a
hundred hearings that we have
carried out and which made it possible to feed
the procedure the legal procedure
in terms of specialization I can only
mention also the work which
was done at the level of the cyber of the
digital besides in a general way
in our files and in particular in the
most important  we are developing more
and more this aspect of cyber of fighting
cybercrim and research in
cyber space so the investigations
were diligent immediately in the
day of the facts both to the
open sources in the factory but also on the
Darknet to evaluate the  activity of the
questioning of our police custody on
social networks and in cyberspace
and I also cannot fail to
mention the
international and European police cooperation that we
have implemented and which has been, I
underline this, of great  quality with
all of our European partners,
it was important to develop this
technical police cooperation, in
particular with regard to the course of the
respondent, as you said Madam
Public Prosecutor, his
respondent left Syria via
Turkey  arrived in Sweden where he had
settled for several years
and then resumed his journey
within the countries of the European Union and
the Schengen area via Italy
Switzerland before arriving on our
territory it was therefore necessary  to
develop this police cooperation
to find out more about his on his
career these are
the means that I wanted to
give you the means of the
judicial police which were implemented in
this in this file we acted in 48
hours within the framework  of
flagrante delicto and we are now going to the
central direction of the
judicial police will now be seized of the
follow-up to the investigation under the authority of the
investigating magistrates who have
indicted the police custody this morning it is
obvious that the means  that we have
deployed the significant means that we
have deployed in the context of
flagrante delicto will continue to be
implemented under the aegis of the
investigating magistrates to develop the
investigations and try to understand
in particular, but this is not the only axis
of  work try to understand
in particular the motivations the motives of the
indicted following this heinous act
here is what I could tell you about
the means mobilized by the
judicial police and before closing this
press conference I
wanted to greet the citizens who
spoke actions have  preserve
human lives obviously the commitment of
the emergency services, of which you have
understood, and the action was decisive
for the preservation of human lives
and the responsiveness of the
Annecy public security services which,
through their intervention, made it possible  to make
these criminal selections I
also wanted to thank the PJ whose
investigators in less than 48 hours
achieved an extremely large number
so it was possible to develop
investigations here thank you thank you